flight attendants from spirit airlines  are showing their frustrations outside  of harry reid international airport  there were other major picketing events  across the country in dallas and orlando  just over the weekend spirit canceled  more than 3 500 u.s flights  they're more concerned about money and  you know charging for every little thing  as opposed to just  being supportive and being  caring towards their customers when  you're on a plane and what they may need  even if it is just you know  a glass of water  you can't really get a glass of water  flight attendants say the budget airline  had four major mass flight cancellations  since august spirit did release a  statement saying quote we've been  through so much together throughout the  pandemic and we are committed to making  the necessary investments to build a  stronger and more resilient airline for  both our team members and guests